[Music]
there's a common misconception that if
you like to meticulously organize your
things keep your hands clean or plan out
your weekends to the last detail
you might have OCD in fact OCD which
stands for obsessive compulsive disorder
is a serious psychiatric condition that
is frequently misunderstood by society
and mental health professionals alike so
let's start by debunking some myths myth
one repetitive or ritualistic behaviors
are synonymous with OCD as its name
suggests obsessive compulsive disorder
has two aspects the intrusive thoughts
images or impulses known as obsessions
and the behavioral compulsions people
engage in to relieve the anxiety the
obsessions caused the kinds of actions
that people often associate with OCD
like excessive hand-washing or checking
things repeatedly may be examples of
obsessive or compulsive tendencies that
many of us exhibit from time to time but
the actual disorder is far more rare and
can be quite debilitating people
affected have little or no control over
their obsessive thoughts and compulsive
behaviors which tend to be
time-consuming and interfere with work
school or social life to the point of
causing significant distress this set of
diagnostic criteria is what separates
people suffering from OCD from those who
may just be a bit more meticulous or
hygiene obsessed than usual myth 2 the
main symptom of OCD is excessive
hand-washing
although hand-washing is the most common
image of OCD in popular culture
obsessions and compulsions can take many
different forms obsessions can manifest
as fears of contamination and illness
worries about harming others or
preoccupations with numbers patterns
morality or sexual identity and
compulsions can range from excessive
cleaning or double checking to the
fastidious arrangement of objects or
walking and predetermined
myth three individuals with OCD don't
understand that they are acting
irrationally many individuals with OCD
actually understand the relationship
between their obsessions and compulsions
quite well being unable to avoid these
thoughts and actions despite being aware
of their irrationality is part of the
reason why OCD is so distressing OCD
sufferers report feeling crazy for
experiencing anxiety based on irrational
thoughts and finding it difficult to
control their responses so what exactly
causes OCD the frustrating answer is we
don't really know however we have some
important clues OCD is considered a
neurobiological disorder in other words
research suggests that OCD sufferers
brains are actually hardwired to behave
in a certain fashion research has
implicated three regions of the brain
variously involved in social behavior
and complex cognitive planning voluntary
movement and emotional and motivational
responses the other piece of the puzzle
is that OCD is associated with low
levels of serotonin a neurotransmitter
that communicates between brain
structures and helps regulate vital
processes such as mood aggression
impulse control sleep appetite body
temperature and pain but our serotonin
and activity in these brain regions the
sources of OCD for symptoms of an
unknown underlying cause of the disorder
we probably won't know until we have a
much more intimate understanding of the
brain the good news is there are
effective treatments for OCD including
medications which increase serotonin in
the brain by limiting its reabsorption
by brain cells behavioral therapy that
gradually desensitizes patients to their
anxieties and in some cases
electroconvulsive therapy or surgery
when OCD doesn't respond to other forms
of treatment knowing that your own brain
is lying to you while not being able to
resist its commands can be agonizing but
with knowledge and understanding comes
the power to seek help and future
research into
the brain may finally provide the
answers we're looking for
[Music]